c'est une histoire très mystique
un rite de passage de jeunes garçons une
histoire de famille intime qui s'est déroulée dans un monde épique
quel était le père je ne pourrai jamais oublier
combien il
t'aimait coupon Kubo les deux cordes donnent l'impression que
c'est juste une expérience incroyablement riche
pour une variété de  raisons mais la
raison la plus claire est qu'il y a des monstres
dedans
les monstres de Kubo sont évidemment une partie
assez importante et passionnante du
film ce qu'ils soulignent c'était l'échelle
ils étaient tous d'énormes créatures nous
n'avions certainement pas fait ça avant et je
pense que le  l'échelle de celui-ci n'a jamais été
faite auparavant, mais le plus gros était notre
maître squelette géant dans la salle des
os hé j'ai un os à choisir avec
vous voyez parce qu'il est fait d'os ici
dans l'embarras dans notre monde ce
serait une centaine  monstre de pied au début j'étais
assez nerveux et un peu effrayé
personne n'avait animé une marionnette aussi grande
avant s'il était assemblé ce squelette
il ne pouvait pas vraiment tenir dans ce
bâtiment les monstres à Cuba  a vraiment
repoussé les limites de la fabrication de marionnettes et de la
technologie, l'un des plus grands monstres
auxquels j'ai dû faire face dans ce film était
le genre de créature sous-marine de quelque chose qui
disait qu'il y avait un jardin de glace le
jardin de I jardin des yeux ou ses
globes oculaires géants scandaleux  sur les tiges,
il y avait beaucoup de discussions au
début sur l'échelle à laquelle cela devrait être à la
fin, sur ce qu'ils mettaient les boules de bingo
et une fois que nous avions décidé que le globe oculaire
devait être ce grand puits, cela signifiait que
la créature entière  devait mesurer huit pieds de
haut oh, puis notre
département le plus contrôlé est allé un peu plus loin et
ils ont développé un système d'encodeur qui a
capté les coordonnées d'une boule de bowling,
c'est certainement la chose la plus éclatante que
nous ayons jamais faite
si l'histoire va  travail, les
méchants doivent être incroyablement dangereux
et terrifiants. Le
monstre le plus effrayant d'Okubo devrait être
la bête de la lune. Je pense que la bête de la lune est
la plus terrifiante. Il est vraiment basé sur
un prêtre ou un poisson qui existe vraiment.  sted
qui m'a toujours effrayé
SAP motion a un grand héritage
pour donner vie à des créatures, nous
poursuivons toujours cet héritage,
j'étais définitivement une sorte de la prochaine
génération d'une certaine manière, c'est comme un hommage,
je pense, à l'ancien stop-motion  des monstres
mais les nôtres sont meilleurs l'histoire était si
bonne que nous voulions vraiment la soutenir et
faire en sorte que cela ressemble à une aventure pour
tout le monde
Je me souviens de cet avion
c'était là que mon père se préparait pour
sa quête
avec chaque film que nous réalisons nous voulons
faire quelque chose d'unique  quelque chose d'original
pour raconter des histoires qui ne sont généralement pas
racontées dans l'animation, nous avançons dans
des directions différentes et Kubo est
certainement la chose la plus épique que
nous ayons jamais faite.
son noyau qui désosse les deux cordes est
un film de samouraï en stop-motion et comme nous l'avons vu,
Rakuten a développé le film au fil du temps, il
est devenu quelque chose qui était beaucoup plus, il
ne s'agit pas seulement de combattre des monstres, vous
savez, il s'agit d'amour
c'est une question de confiance c'est une grande
aventure mythique impressionnante l'une des choses
qui m'a vraiment attiré dans le projet était
la relation entre le scarabée Kubo et le
singe devez-vous jouer avec votre nourriture oui
Kubo passe de sa vie simple au
grand monde effrayant là-bas et ainsi de suite  il
doit traverser ce voyage pour accomplir
ce destin héroïque et il y a toutes
sortes de défis en cours de route, eh bien,
vous savez que tout était trop
ambitieux, mais si quelque chose
semble impossible, c'est normalement lorsque nous
montrons un intérêt pour  si
vous connaissez un grand film d'action épique qui n'est
tout simplement pas quelque chose qui se fait généralement
en stop-motion et pour une bonne raison comment
styliser l'eau comment faire
des monstres massifs émergeant de l'
ombre comment faire en sorte que ces
personnages prennent vie dans  d'une manière qui semble réelle,
nous n'avions certainement pas fait cela auparavant et
je pense que l'ampleur de cela n'a jamais été
faite auparavant, il y a quelque chose d'aussi
transparent à ce sujet lorsque la technologie peut
épouser la narration comme ça  C'est vraiment
puissant, nous sommes maintenant ici à la fin d'un
processus de cinq ans et c'est vraiment un
témoignage de tous les artistes qui ont
relevé ce défi impossible et l'ont transformé
en cette incroyable pièce de cinéma